well trevor williams making the start
for the cubs for all pitchers since 2019
that have made at least 40 starts
williams has the highest or worst era of
all eligible pitchers but against the
new york mets
he is good three and one 2.08 in his
career luis skier made to lay things off
two for two in this series he's got a
588 on base percentage to start the year
got in on his hands that time here's
half barely has to move and ian
we're out number one last night lindor
had a solid night at the plate going
three for four including his first mets
home run that came in the first inning
lindor in the air down the left field
line long run
sliding
and ian makes the grab
the center fielder in left with a long
run and made a heck of a play always a
good night to pitch when guys make plays
like that behind you
you see the break one quick to find the
wall kind of gauge uh okay what i got to
do here i got to leave my feeder i'm
going to go head long into this wall and
that's no fun
rough road trip for dom so far just two
for 15. he's been crushing fastballs and
not hitting anything else
he gets a fast ball and he crushes one
to right it's down for a base hit i love
when those things pay off immediately
dom came into the night hitting 474
against fastballs oh 42 against
everything else and he adds to that two
balls and a strike on pete alonso and
now trevor williams delivers to alonso
hits a sharp crown ball backhanded by
bodhi nice play throws to first to get
him
the cubs flash some fancy leather
defensively in the top of the first
inning excellent plays by ian happ in
left and david bodie the second baseman
he was over on the left side of the bag
as they shifted the hitters that are in
the lineup are 15 for 26 off lucasy
his first start three innings and three
uh three innings three runs um but
before that he had two scoreless innings
in relief as they try to build up his
pitch count the switch hitter betting
right-handed the lead off the bottom of
the first for the cubs with no score
and happens when on the ground nice
stopped by guillory from his knees he
throws him out
guillerme in the lineup for his defense
and he shows it off on the first play in
the first inning
what a play by guillerme gets a short
stop to smile
mccasey is going to give up a lot of
ground balls to the left side so you've
got to be ready to go and guillerme has
been ready since day one 2-2 coming and
contreras goes down on the high fastball
and lucasy's got his first strikeout two
down good combination there by luke
casey the prior fastball was too high
and he came back
more
into a place where contreras would offer
so two out of nobody on now chris bryant
ryan two for seven in this series
bryant swings and misses strike three
and luke casey gets back-to-back
strikeouts two out and nobody on
and the church strikes out duffy that's
four strikeouts through the first two
innings for joey lucasi
strong start for joey six up and six
down no score after two and he's walked
back-to-back hitters here and ian happ
at the plate
he cracks one to right but right at
conforto and he reaches back to get it
tagging at second is mariznick and he'll
move over to third i wonder if they'll
check that because that did drop but i
think he i think he had it on the
exchange he dropped it
well the runner at first base williams
stayed put
so if they did if he did drop it that's
would get a force play at second base so
now two outs runners on the corners and
wilson contreras coming up and the
one-two pitch on the way a swing and a
smash off the body of lucasia rolls over
toward first and there's no play a run
scores it's an enfield single for wilson
contreras
that ball hit the body of luke casey and
it rolled over halfway between first and
second with the shift on there was no
way for vr the second baseman to make a
play now some concern for lucasie if he
got his throwing hand on that ball ryan
chick low the head athletic trainer out
to have a look so now a damage
controlling at bat for lucasie as he
takes on chris bryant the bases on balls
have come back to sting joey lucasi
left center field that one towards the
gap that one is off the wall
williams in to score contreras headed to
the plate
and he's in there
and brian ends up on third
and it is three nothing kb comes through
with a rocket to left center field kb
gets a pitch to handle and he hammers
this ball and the only reason it doesn't
go out of the ballpark is it's got a
little bit of top spin on it and that
keeps it in the yard see the full shift
on against tom smith got the base it off
the fastball his first time up
and that fastball cranked out to left
field back toward the wall and it's off
the ivy played on the carrum by half dom
heads to second and slides in safely
with a double fool me once
fool me twice
two fastballs two hits for dom smith
this one an opposite field double he
took a curveball took a change up just
waited for the fastball
second nobody out pete alonso's the
batter
alonso it's this ball deep in the air
toward left it's way back and it's long
gone this one goes to the back of the
bleachers and straight away left field
as pete alonso has homered for the
second straight night he's gotten the
mitts on the board with a two-run shot
and the cubs lead has shrunk to three to
two as that ball has already been thrown
back from the bleachers out in left
field hanging breaking ball from
williams just a bullet pete is literally
flexing his muscles to his teammates as
he walks back into the met's dugout cub
right-hander trevor williams ready for
the o2 pitch it's on the way to nimmo
strike three called a fastball right
down the middle
it surprised nemo he was not looking for
that and that ends the inning
big choke up by rizzo with two strikes
he's done that his entire career
you can do that when you're right on the
plate as he is
like barry bonds rusty stop
he gets jammed again it bloops one to
center but in comes pilar to grab it
three perfect innings for sean reid
foley in his mets debut jd davis swung
the batwell that's not been the problem
for him two hits including an rbi double
yesterday homered in the game on tuesday
and he drives one deep left center field
back toward the gap marisnick and it's
off the wall bouncing away from arizona
vr is going to score easily and now
davis to second he will stop there the
game is tied jd davis off the ivy for an
rbi pinch hit double and the mets have
drawn even at three and three
for all his defensive struggles jd just
continues to rank apple bat right-handed
he's over three tonight one for nine in
this series
and half goes down on strikes and
they're at two men down big strikeout
for aaron luke here he is on back to
back nights now needing one big out here
and it's wilson contreras two and two
the count now the pitch to contreras
swung out and missed strike three got
him with a slider side retired so a lead
off triple is wasted by the cubs so
wiggler after striking on mcneil walks
guillermo and lindor back to back and
that'll get dom smith to the plate with
the bases loaded the pitch on the way
ground ball a second one hop cody goes
to buy us one over to first for a double
play a double play ends the inning four
six three cubs with a chance to win the
game tie game 3-3 bottom of the 10th
inning 1-1 to jay hey
step right field baez comes in hayward's
the hero in in 10.
cubs win
4-3
j-hay off the bench
the celebration is on